Hello, this is 6 Minute
English from BBC
Learning English. I'm Neil
and I'm Phil.
And now that we've done our hellos,
let's hear some greetings in different
languages from around the world.
But what do these languages have
in common?
I'm afraid
I don't know what they have in common
because I don't recognise any
of them.
Well, sadly, the one thing uniting
these languages
is that they're all endangered.
We often hear
about animals at risk of extinction,
but a recent study by the Australian
National University found that
out of the world's
seven thousand existing languages,
half are under threat.
But what can be done
to save languages from dying out.
That's what we'll be discussing
in this programme
and as usual, we'll be learning
some useful new vocabulary as well.
But first,
I have a question for you,
Phil, and it's about a country
which used to be one
of the most linguistically rich
places on earth,
Australia. Before European settlers
arrived in the 1800s,
Australia had
over two hundred languages spoken by
the native Aboriginal people who had
lived there for thousands of years.
Many Aboriginal
languages were destroyed by
the brutal laws of the
Australian government at the time.
However, some survived.
So, which of the following Aboriginal
languages is still spoken today
is it a) Djinang
b) Alawa
or c) Gagadu?
I'll guess it's Djinang.
OK Phil, I'll reveal the answer
later in the programme.
The sad truth is that
it was no accident that
the Aboriginal languages died out,
given the cruel treatment
of Aboriginal people.
Children were removed
from their mothers
and sent to schools thousands of miles
away to learn English, and even today
Aboriginal communities experience
racism and poverty.
Another
aboriginal language,
Barngala, officially died
in 1960
when its last native speaker,
elder Mooney Davies passed away.
But Barngala
has been brought back to life.
And today, it's spoken between parents
and children and even learned in school.
So, how did a dead language with
no living speakers come back to life.
The unusual answer involves a dictionary
and a professor of linguistics.
Here's Professor Ghil'ad Zuckerman
telling his story for BBC
World Service Programme,
People Fixing The World,
I had a dictionary, written by
a German Lutheran Christian
missionary in 1844.
His name was Clamor Wilhelm
Schumann, and he wrote the dictionary
with up to 3500 words,
which is a lot,
because he wanted to Christianise
the, in quotation marks, "heathens".
So, it's a topsy-turvy righting
the wrong of the past by using
a tool, written for one goal
in order to achieve
the diametrically opposite goal.
Professor Zuckerman found an
English-to-Barngala dictionary, written
in 1844 by a German missionary,
a person sent
to a foreign country to teach their
religion to the people living there.
Christian missionaries used
the dictionary to teach English
to what they called
Aboriginal "heathens".
'Heathen' is an old fashioned word for
someone who belongs to no religion
or to a religion that is not Christianity,
Judaism or Islam.
Professor Zuckerman puts the words
'heathen' in quotation marks.
The phrase 'in quotation marks'
is used to show the actual words,
someone else has written or said
but here the phrase is used ironically.
Professor Zuckerman
is questioning the real meaning
of the word 'heathens'.
He is signalling that he doesn't
think Aboriginals are heathens
at all - a bit like adding a wink
at the end of a sentence
so people know you're not serious.
What is ironic is that Professor
Zuckerman used the missionary's
dictionary,
not to spread Christianity
and English, but to save an Aboriginal
language from extinction.
So, he calls it
'topsy-turvy', meaning upside down.
Professor Zuckerman also says he is
'righting the wrongs of the past'
a phrase which means doing something
to correct
a historical injustice from the past -
in this case,
the destruction
of Aboriginal language and culture.
Speaking your own language
is about more than communication,
it means knowing your roots
and feeling good about yourself.
I think it's time you reveal
the answer to your question, Neil.
OK, well Phil,
you guessed that Djinang was
another living Aboriginal language,
which was the correct answer!
Right, let's recap the vocabulary
we've learned
starting with 'missionary'-
someone sent to spread their religion
to a foreign country.
'Heathen' is an old-fashioned name for
someone who believes in no religion.
The phrase 'in quotation marks' is used
to show the actual words spoken
or written by someone else.
It can also be used ironically,
to show scepticism, disagreement
or belief that a word is misused.
'Topsy-turvy' means upside down
or disorganised.
If you 'right the wrongs of the past',
you tried to correct
a historical injustice.
Once again our six minutes are up.
Goodbye for now.
Bye.